Hallo, ein schöner guten Abend. Mein Name ist Hawa Ingas. Heute bin ich als Assistant,
Assistant auf dieser Station zuständig. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch
führen. Sind Sie damit verstanden? Ja, bin ich.
Zuerst brauche ich ein paar Informationen über Ihre persönliche Daten. Ich heiße Sie.
Ich heiße Lisa Niesmann. Können Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen langsam vorstellen?
Ja, Niesmann schreibt sich N-I-E-S-M-A-N-N. Zwei Mal N. Danke Frau Niesmann. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 47 Jahre alt. 47 Jahre alt. Wie groß sind Sie?
1,62 Meter. Wie schwer sind Sie? 79 kg. Danke Frau Niesmann. Wie heißt Ihr Haushalts- oder
Ihre Haushalts-? Das ist Herr Dr. Schulze. Danke.
Als Sie besparen haben. Seit zwei Tagen habe ich Schmerzen im linken Bein,
sondern das im linken Unterschenkel und der Schmerz nimmt weiter zu. Der wird immer schlimmer.
Ich ist kribbelt im Bein, besonders auf der Außenseite des Unterschenkels, kribbelt es.
Das geht bis in den Fußrücken. Der Schmerz verschlemmert sich auch, wenn ich husten muss oder wenn ich niesen muss.
Wie können Sie Ihre Schmerzen bestreiten? Das ist dunkel oder krankfaltig?
Das ist mehr so ein bisschen drückend, als wenn jemand ein Gummi um das Bein rumwickelt, so zusammendrückt.
So ist der Schmerz mehr.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala?
Von 0 bis 10, wobei 0 ist kein Schmerz, sind ein unterertretter Schmerz.
Ich würde sagen zwischen 6 und 7.
Vor 2000 waren die Schmerzen leichter, oder?
Ja, da waren die vielleicht zwischen 4 und 5.
Ich strahle die Schmerzen aus oder nur im linken Unterschenkel?
Sie sind im linken Bein und besonders im linken Unterschenkel, auf der Außenseite mehr.
Gibt es ein Auslöser für die Schmerzen, vielleicht Unfall oder was anderes?
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Ich habe gestern, vormittag aus dem Auto, ein Mineralwasserkasten in unsere Wohnung rausgetragen.
Das war sehr anstrengend, aber normalerweise schaffe ich das immer.
Vielleicht liegt es daran, ich kann das aber nicht sagen.
Sie haben gesagt, wenn Sie Pusten oder Niesen stärken, gibt es etwas, was ihr schmerzt, wie das?
Ja, wenn ich auf dem Sofa liege und die Beine anziehe, die Knieanziege zum Körper, dann ist es etwas weniger, aber nur etwas.
Haben Sie diese Beschwerde früher in der Hand?
Nicht so stark. Ich hatte schon mal häufiger Rückenschmerzen, da war ich auch mal beim Orthopäden gewesen.
Da wurde damals sogar auch eine Computertomographie gemacht, aber die haben gesagt, es sei kein Bandscheibenvorfall gewesen, das war aber vor 3 Jahren.
Ich hatte da auch starke Schmerzen, auch im linken Bein, aber nicht so stark wie jetzt.
Das ist jetzt neu.
Haben Sie die Schwellung im Bein?
Ich habe es nicht bemerkt.
Meine Beine sind immer etwas abends etwas dicker, habe ich den Eindruck, besonders wenn es warm ist im Sommer,
aber das linke Bein ist nicht stärker geschwollen als das rechte.
Okay, gibt es Rötung oder Überwarmung?
Hab ich nicht beobachtet.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Haben Sie etwas Ungewöhnliches, wenn man wie blauliche zum Beispiel Rötung farbe?
Blaue Farbe?
Nein.
Ich hatte vor einigen Wochen einen Zeckenbiss.
Den hatte ich so an der linken Leiste, da an der Hüfte, an der Leiste, ein Zeckenbiss.
Die Zecke habe ich selber entfernt.
Mein Nachbar hat gesagt, ich soll da eine Wundsalbe drauf machen.
Ich glaube, die heißt PVP Salbe.
Die habe ich da drauf gemacht und die Rötung ging dann irgendwann auch weg,
aber ich muss auch zugeben, ich habe mich darum nicht mehr so gekümmert.
Das war so vor sieben Wochen, war das?
Sieben Wochen.
Haben Sie Angeschlagenheit oder Krankheitsgefühl?
Abgeschlagenheit?
Ja, abgeschlagenen Krankheitsgefühl.
Hauptsächlich ist es der Schmerz.
Ich habe jetzt nicht gut geschlafen in den letzten zwei Nächten,
deswegen bin ich etwas müde und abgeschlagen, aber sonst so kenne ich das nicht.
Haben Sie etwas gegen Schmerzen eingenommen?
Ich habe gestern Abend mal eine Tablette Paracetamol genommen für Erwachsene,
aber das hat nicht groß geholfen.
Danke, Frau Miesmann.
Haben Sie Wusten oder Atemmord oder Herzprobleme?
Wuste, ich wuste häufiger, aber da sagen alle meine Familie,
das hängt mit meinem Rauchen zusammen.
Sie sagen immer, ich habe einen Raucherwusten, aber Atemnot habe ich nicht.
Seit wann fangen Sie?
Ich rauche jetzt seit 20 Jahren, 25 Jahren.
Nach den Geburt der Kinder habe ich das Rauchen angefangen.
Wie viel Zigaretten fangen Sie?
10 Zigaretten am Tag, manchmal etwas mehr.
Haben Sie Schlafprobleme?
Normalerweise nicht.
Ich muss relativ früh aufstehen, weil ich arbeite in einer Conditorei.
Da muss ich morgens um halb sechs anfangen,
aber mich komme mit dem Schlaf eigentlich ganz gut zurecht.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein, ich muss nachts einmal auf Toilette in der Regel.
Heute trinke ich abends relativ viel Tee und Mineralwasser.
Aber ich kann danach wieder gut einschlafen.
Stuhlgang ist in Ordnung.
Danke, Frau Miesmann.
Jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Vorerkrankung wissen.
Haben Sie eine krönliche Krankheit?
Bluthochdruck, Diabetes?
Ja, Bluthochdruck habe ich.
Seit ungefähr fünf Jahren nehme ich da auch Tabletten ein.
Was ist das?
Ich habe ein Zettel, da steht drauf Walzatan.
8, da nehme ich morgens eine Tablette und abends eine Tablette.
Dann nehme ich noch Bisoprol, 5, morgens eine und abends eine halbe.
Okay.
Haben Sie andere Krankheiten?
Ich muss noch eine Tablette einnehmen für die Schilddrüse,
damit die nicht wieder groß wird und wächst.
Das heißt, Euterox 50, eine Tablette am Tag.
Weil ich bin an der Schilddrüse vor vier Jahren operiert worden.
Die war vergrößert, hatte zwei Knoten.
Das hat man versucht mit Tabletten zu verkleinern,
aber die Knoten gingen nicht weg.
Dann hat man gesagt, das muss man operieren.
Und Ihre Schilddrüse total entstand?
Auf der einen Seite ist noch ein ganz kleiner Rest übrig geblieben.
Aber ich muss eben regelmäßig diese Tabletten nehmen,
wurde mir gesagt, sonst würde die Schilddrüse wieder wachsen.
Okay.
Gab es eine Komplikation nach der Operation?
Oder war das ein bisschen...
Ich wurde schon einmal wegen der Schilddrüse operiert.
Als Kind war ich, glaube ich, so 10 Jahre alt.
Da wurden die Mandeln operiert.
Und da war ich dann noch jünger, glaube ich, 6 oder 7 Jahre alt.
Vorher hatte ich einen Bruch am Bauchnabel.
Dieser Bauchnabelbruch war ziemlich groß,
und deswegen musste der auch operiert werden.
Okay.
Danke, Frau Müslmann.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeit?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder beide Bedarf außer
die Wassertaben, Brüso-Prolör und Eutrocks.
Andere Medikamente?
Nein, nur gestern Abend einmal diese Schmerztablette,
sonst nehme ich keine Schmerztabletten.
Okay.
Sind Sie voll standig?
Ja, mein Hausarzt sagte, im letzten Frühjahr war ich da
zur Untersuchung, der sagte, das passt alles.
Im Schlitz ist gut, da muss im Augenblick nichts gemacht werden.
Okay.
Bekommen Sie Ihre ...
Periode?
Ja, Ihre Periode regelmäßig.
Ja, das ist auch regelmäßig zur Frau und Ärztin,
zur Vorsorgeuntersuchung, und das war bisher in Ordnung.
Ja, das ist okay.
Okay.
Gibt es eine Krankheit oder ein kronischer Krankheit
in Ihrer Familie bei Ihrem Eltern oder Großeltern?
Also, mein Vater, der ist 79 Jahre alt,
der hat eine chronische Bronchitis, also viel schwerer,
noch als ich, sagt man auch, er hat viel geraucht früher
und hat auch in einer Firma gearbeitet, wo sehr viel Staub war
und die Luft nicht gut, jedenfalls,
sie hat eine chronische Bronchitis, und er hat auch
die Schaufensterkrankheit, also durch Blutungsstörungen
in den Beinen, da kann er auch immer nur einige Meter gehen
und muss dann wieder anhalten.
Man hat das schon versucht, mit einer Katheterbehandlung
zu verbessern, aber das war nicht sehr erfolgreich.
Die Mutter, die ist 78 Jahre alt,
die hat Alterszucker und die hat auch hohe Blutdruck,
so wie ich.
Habersehgeschwester?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester, die hat entzündliches Gelenkräumer
und die ist 48 Jahre alt, ne, die ist zweier älter als ich, ja.
Die ist auch schwer beeinträchtigt damit,
die muss starke Medikamente nehmen
und häufig Blut kontrollieren lassen.
Dann habe ich noch einen Bruder, der ist 51 Jahre alt,
der hat Gicht und Gichtanfälle gehabt,
besonders eben im großen Zegelenk, das ist wohl sehr schmerzhaft.
Und, ja.
Erschuldigung, ist ihr Bruder 51 Jahre alt?
Ja, 52, ich glaube er wird jetzt 42, ich habe durcheinander gebracht.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder, Sie haben gesagt, ja.
Ja, zwei Kinder, die sind gesund, die sind 16 und 18 Jahre alt
und ja, die sind gesund.
Okay, danke Frau Nischmann, sind Sie hier drei Jahre alt?
Ja, ich wohne mit meinem Mann zusammen, die Kinder wohnen auch noch bei uns.
Okay, und Sie arbeiten als, Sie arbeiten in Konditore, ja?
Ja, ich bin eine, ich bin Konditorin und, ja.
Okay, haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Nein, die Arbeit, ich bin mehr oder weniger alleine für mich,
wenn ich meine Torten und Kuchen mache, da habe ich keinen großen Stress.
Also das ist eine sehr angenehme Arbeit und die macht mir auch sehr viel Spaß.
Ja, das ist sehr gut.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, das könnte besser sein, ich mache einmal in der Woche, mache ich Yoga
und manchmal treffe ich mich mit der Nachbarin zur Nordic Walking.
Nordic Walking, das ist Gehen mit Stöcken, wenn man geht.
Okay, danke Frau Nischmann, ich habe ein paar Fragen vergessen.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nicht regelmäßig, vielleicht pro Woche zwei Glas Wein.
Pro Woche zwei Glas Wein, okay.
Und haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein.
Waren Sie in Weste als im Auslad?
Ja, ich war aber nur in Österreich im Sommer zwei Wochen
und dann war ich im April einmal drei Tage in Paris, aber sonst nicht.
Okay.
Und noch eine Frage über Ihre Beine.
Haben Sie Ihre Beine bewegen können?
Ich kann das Bein bewegen, aber ich darf es nicht zu viel bewegen,
weil das dann wieder mehr schmerzt.
Am besten geht es, wenn ich auf dem Rücken liege und die Knie anziehe.
Okay.
Gut.
Okay, danke Frau Nischmann.
Ich habe meine alle Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich mache mir schon Sorgen, was das sein kann.
So einen Schmerz habe ich ja noch gar nicht gehabt, so stark.
Ja, ich kann jetzt nicht genau sagen, was Sie haben,
was Ihnen gefällt.
Aber zuerst muss ich Sie körperlich untersuchen
und ein paar Leberuntersuchungen machen.
Ich muss Blut abnehmen und dann muss mein Auferar darüber sprechen.
Dann werde ich Sie Schritt für Schritt informieren.
Okay.
Gut, so können wir das machen.
Gut, dann haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit, sich vorzubereiten.
Denken Sie an die Übersetzung der Patientensprache
in medizinische Fachausdrücke.
Zum Beispiel wie, ja, was kann man sagen, Kribbeln oder Husten
oder Luftnot oder so etwas.
Oder die Operationen, dass Sie die gut übersetzen
in die Fachsprache, die Mandeloperation,
die eine Nabelbruchoperation, wenn das möglich ist.
Ja, und die anderen Kollegen, die zugehört haben,
die können gerne noch Fragen stellen oder Ergänzungen.
Ich würde vielleicht noch eine Frage stellen.
Ich habe eine Frage für Sie, Frau Nitzmann.
Können Sie die Röhrung genau beschreiben vor sieben Wochen?
Hat zum Beispiel die Röhrung eine zentrale Ablassung?
Zentrale Ablassung, was ist das?
Ich meine zentrale Belass und die rundum Röhrung.
Das war rot in der Leiste.
Nach dem Zeckenbiss war das rot und das wurde auch ein bisschen größer.
Dann habe ich diese 2-3 Mal diese Salbe drauf gemacht, diese braune Salbe.
Dann habe ich das aber aus den Augen verloren vergessen.
Die Röhrung war vielleicht 3-4 cm groß.
Im Anfang wurde sie ein bisschen größer,
aber nachher habe ich das nicht mehr beobachtet.
Die 2. Frage ist, haben Sie Gelenkschmerzen in anderen Körperteilen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Für jetzt das war alles.
Vielleicht noch eine Ergänzungsfrage.
Hatten Sie in letzter Zeit in den letzten Wochen einen Unfall?
Oder einen Sturz?
Ist da etwas Besonderes gewesen?
Nein, Sie hatten keinen Unfall, keinen Sturz.
Da war nichts Besonderes.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, dass es eine schwere Sache ist?
Am Tag vorher habe ich eine Kiste mit Mineralwasser aus dem Auto gehoben
und in die Wohnung getragen.
Das war anstrengend.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das zusammen mit dem Auto denke.
Eine Frage, ob Sie die Schmerzen ohne Beschwerden gehen konnten
oder mussten Sie Pause machen?
Ja.
Mussten Sie anhalten?
Nein, da ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Ich habe regelmäßig fast zu Fuß zu arbeiten.
Ich fahre kurz mit der Straßenbahn und musste 500 Meter zu Fuß laufen.
Das hat mir bisher nichts ausgemacht.
Da musste ich nie anhalten.
Bei der Bewegung hat sich die Schmerzen verschlimmert?
Ja, bei Husten, Niesen und Bewegungen.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestatten Herr O'Garras.
Wir können anfangen.
Bitte schön.
Ja, guten Tag Herr O'Garras.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine Patientin vorstellen. Darf ich?
Ja, bitte.
Die Patientin heißt Lisa Nisman.
Sie ist 47 Jahre alt, 1,62 Meter groß und 79 kg schwer.
Die Patientin steht bei uns,
und hat seit 2 Tagen
auf der linken Seite Schmerzen geschmackt.
Sie klagt über die Parallelste auf der linken Seite.
Sie fragt, ob sie sich auf die Schmerzen verschlimmert haben.
Ich fasse kurz zusammen.
Frau Nisman ist eine 47 Jahre Patientin.
Sie klagt seit 2 Tagen über zunehmende Schmerzen.
Nur im linken Unterschenkel oder im linken Bein?
Im linken Bein, besonders im unterschenkel aus der Seite.
Sie macht über Schmerzen im linken Bein,
überwiegend im linken Unterschenkel lateral.
Der Schmerz wird als dumpf beschrieben und drückend.
Es stehen Kribbelparistäsien,
besonders im Unterschenkel lateral,
die bis in den Fußrücken ausstrahlen.
Äußere Veränderungen wie Erhythm,
Yedem oder Zyuanose,
die Patienten verneint.
Wie stark ist der Schmerz auf der Skala?
Jetzt sind die Schmerzen 6 bis 7.
Der Schmerz hat leicht zugenommen.
Es gibt eventuell ein Auslöser für den Schmerz?
Es gibt einen Unfallereignis?
Nein, es gibt keinen Unfall.
Aber die Patientin hat gesagt,
sie hat eine schwere Kiste aufgetragen.
Vielleicht kann das ein Auslöser sein.
Aber die Patientin gibt es so an.
Es gibt akute Stuhl oder Hahn in Kontinenz?
Nein, sie haben keine Probleme
beim Wasserlösen oder Stuhlgang.
Jetzt auch aktuell nicht.
Sie können das Wasser halten.
Die Patienten fragen, können Sie das Wasser halten?
Die Mikzon steuern.
Eine wichtige Frage in diesbezüglich.
Hat die Patientin die Schmerzen schon einmal gehabt?
Sie haben häufiger Druckenschmerzen.
Sie war früher bei einer Orte,
die unter sucht.
Sie war bei einer Orte.
Ein City war bei ihr durchgeführt.
Aber es gab keine Auffälligkeit.
Sie klagte in den letzten Jahren
über Lumbodor-Salgien,
die auch ins linke Bein oft ausstrahlten.
Sie erfolgte über den Orthopäden
eine Bildgebung in Form eines CTs.
Da fand sich wohl kein Anhalt
für einen Landschreibenvorfall oder Diskusprolaps.
Hat die Patientin
eine chronische Erkrankung?
Die Patientin habe seit fünf Jahren
Arterie-Hypertony.
Sie nehmen dagegen regelmäßig
Wasser tanzt 8 mg, 2 Mal täglich,
Monsieur Prololl 5 mg, 2 Mal,
1 Mal morgen und eine halbe Tablette,
abends ein.
Vor vier Jahren wurde sie
bei ihr eine Troidopterie durchgeführt.
Warum?
Sie hatte eine Strom
und genozen
Stromnodosa.
Sie wurde subtotal
pteryodektomiert oder erfolgte eine subtotale Pteryodektomie.
Die Patientin, diesbezüglich Medikamente ein?
Sie nehmen euch 5 mg,
einmal täglich ein.
Als Kind
wurde ein
umdikalhernektomiert.
Einmal erfolgt eine tonsilektomie
und umdikalhernektomiert.
Oder eine herneotomie wegen umbilikalhernektomiert.
Was ist die Patientin von Beruf?
Sie ist ein Quantitorin.
Es gibt persönliche Risikofaktoren
bei der Patientin.
Neben ihrem leichten
Übergewicht, was man sagen kann,
1,62,79 kg,
ist sicherlich übergewicht.
Ich habe den Bodymassindex nicht im Kopf,
aber das kann ein Risikofaktor sein.
Gibt es sonstige persönliche Risikofaktoren?
Wie verstärkt Alkohol, wie Nikotin?
Sie rach vor 2 Jahren
Zigaretten täglich.
Wie lange?
Vor 20 Jahren.
Das heißt,
10 Paar Konkert.
Es besteht durchaus ein Nikotin-Konsum von 10 Packages.
Und Alkohol.
Sie trinken 2 Glas Wein pro He, Alkohol.
Und in der Familie an der Mese
hat der Vater
in der Patientin
chronische Bruschitis
und perperetheraeschlußkrankheit.
Er ist 79 Jahre alt.
Bei dem 79-jährigen Vater besteht wohl,
wir wissen es nicht genau, eine COPD
und eine PAVK.
Und die Mutter, wie alt ist sie?
Die Mutter ist 78 Jahre alt.
Und hat Diabetes meintestöp 2
und Arterie-Refüttertonie.
Und Schwester ist 49 Jahre alt.
Und hat
Rheumatoide Arthritis.
Und sie ist sehr beeingeschränkt.
Und dann gibt es noch ein Bruder?
Ja, der Bruder ist 52 Jahre alt.
Und er hat Arthritis-Ürkosa.
Oder Arthritis-Urika.
Ja, Arthritis-Urika.
Und hat auch Schaf.
Ja, gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Reise an der Mese?
Sie war in Österreich für 2 Wochen
und einmal in Paris für 3 Tage in Leicester.
Und sie war in Österreich für 2 Wochen.
Sie war in Leicester.
Ja.
Jetzt überlegen Sie noch einmal, bis Sie haben Sie das super gut gemacht.
Überlegen Sie, Sie haben noch eine an einem nestischen Hinweis.
Jetzt unterschlagen. Nicht gebracht.
Denken Sie an, was war in der Leistengegend vor einigen Wochen?
Hatte die Patientin eine Salbe aufgetragen?
Ja.
Sie hatte eine Zäckenstich vor 7 Wochen.
Ja, eine Zäckenstich. Die Fachwelt diskutiert, ob es ein Biss oder Stich ist.
Ja.
Vor circa 7 Wochen hat die Patientin in einen Zäckenbiss
in der linken Leiste. Und sie hat das selbst behandelt mit Salbe.
Wahrscheinlich mit PVP-Salbe.
Das ist die braune Salbe oder Beta-Isadona.
Diese Salbe geht ja gerne in die Wäsche.
Und das hat sie selbst behandelt, aber nicht dem Arzt gezeigt.
Ja.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist ein Bruce-Henler-Adrichtins.
Ja, ich bin nicht sicher, aber...
Also, der Schmerzcharakter.
Es geht nicht darum, ob Sie eine richtige Diagnose stellen.
Versuchen Sie nur, die Parenzialliagnose zu stellen.
Also, es kommen ja mindestens 2 Sachen in Betracht.
Die Patientin klagt über einen Nies- und Hustenschmerz,
der ins Bein einstrahlt, in das linke Bein,
vorwiegend linker Unterschenkel, Latte,
die sich den Fuß rücken.
Da könnte man eventuell daran denken,
dass es sich um einen Wurzelreizyndrom handelt
oder um einen Discos-Brudabs eventuell,
der diese Sythomatik macht.
Und, also, differenzial diagnostisch haben Sie das eben schon gesagt,
muss man an eine Borreliose auch denken.
Ja, zumindest die Borreliose hat ja ganz viele verschiedene Gesichter.
Es ist nicht klassisch immer mit Fieber oder mit Gelenkentzündung einhergehen.
Das kann ja eine reine neurologische Reizung sein, was auch immer.
Aber diese beiden Diagnosen und Differenzialdiagnosen,
die würde ich in diesem Falle nennen.
Ja?
Okay.
Gut.
Oder gibt es Protest von anderen Kollegen?
Die PAVK kommt für meine Begriffe hier nicht in Frage.
Die Patientin hat diesbezüglich eigentlich keine Vorgeschichte.
Sie konnte immer, hat eine freie Gehstrecke gehabt,
von 500 Meter auf ihrem Weg zur Arbeit.
Das spricht nicht unbedingt für eine PAVK.
Und da ist nicht unbedingt so ein reiner Verstärkungsschmerz
durch Husten und Niesen zum Beispiel.
Aber ich denke auf jeden Fall,
dass die PAVK einen Differenzialdiagnosen sagen,
weil sieben und fiesig Jahre,
genau und keine Menoposa,
und Deutsche Mann zum Beispiel.
Also man muss, ja ja, klar.
Ich würde jetzt mal sagen, vorrangig wäre für mich,
verdacht auf, was ist das? L5, S1-Zyndrom, L5 wahrscheinlich.
Links.
Und bei verdacht auf Discos-Prolapse,
vorher hat sie gehoben mit dem Mineralwasserkasten.
Sie hatte schon Jahre vorher Rückenschmerzen.
Das kann jetzt sein.
Sie ist nicht unbedingt sehr trainiert.
Ihr Nordic Walking sporadisch und ihr Yoga,
das hilft ihr da nicht so viel, aber immerhin.
Vielen Dank erst mal für Ihre Bereitschaft.
Sie haben das gut gemacht.
Ich konnte Sie gut verstehen.
Sie haben sich immer Zeit genommen mit den Fragestellen.
Sie haben das nicht überhastet gemacht, nicht zu schnell.
Und auch dann die Vorstellung beim Oberarzt.
Das ist ja dann schon schwieriger.
Dann ist man aufgeregter.
Das haben Sie aber auch, denke ich, sehr gut gemacht.
Ich habe auch die Fachbegriffe.
Haben Sie ganz überwiegend richtig benannt auch,
die Operationen und die subjektiven Beschwerden.
Und der Bein befunden, das finde ich war sehr gut.
Und jetzt frage ich Sie nur, wann machen Sie Ihre Prüfung?
Ich warte auch einen Tag.
Okay, na gut.
Dann will ich Sie nicht weiter unter Druck setzen.
Aber ich finde, das haben Sie sehr gut gemacht.
Ich danke Ihnen.